I would say if a girl can date a guy
without kids yeah do the same but but
it's also like women kind of like men
with kids but men don't like women with
kids and I don't understand why I yeah
but you know it's a thing yeah it is a
thing but I just don't get why yeah well
I'll tell you why there's okay so just
because we're in a modern times it
doesn't change our biology yeah so what
what is a female mating strategy at its
core didn't they so you want to get the
best jeans possible oh yeah yeah so you
want to get like that's why you like
tall men strong men because it's better
jeans for the kids right yes and you
want to get as many resources as
possible yes so like that money that's
why we have gold diggers what's a male
Strat mating strategy to its core I want
to pass on my jeans yeah right obviously
like um to a fertile a fertile woman and
attractive woman so that's why men tend
to date younger women because we we're
more fertile yeah okay